Last of Us part 2 ghost of Tsushima and
the Uncharted movie or get brand-new
release states and fallout 76 might be
adding pets I'm Lucy and welcome to your
safe state for Monday April 27 we got a
new release date for Last of Us part 2
June 19th and Ghost of Tsushima moves by
a couple of weeks to July 17th Last of
Us was previously delayed because of
logistical challenges due to the global
pandemic despite the game nearing
completion on the PlayStation Blog
worldwide studios head hem and health
said these dates are possible due to
quotes and ease in the global
distribution environment ghosts of
Tsushima was originally supposed to come
out on June 26th but has been moved back
by a couple of weeks
an important note sony automatically
cancelled and refunded PlayStation Store
pre-orders when the Last of Us part 2
was delayed earlier this month
if you did digitally preorder the Last
of Us part 2 you please double check
because then you can preload it and you
can play it as soon as it launches whoa
whoa whoa whoa the Uncharted movies
release date has changed too but it
hasn't been delayed it's actually been
brought forward the Uncharted movie
starring Tom Holland as the young Nathan
Drake was previously due to release on
October 8 2021 but it's now been brought
ahead to July 16 2021 the release date
changed as part of a widest Sony
shake-up that saw the release date of
the spider-man far from home sequel
moved to November 5th 2021 and the into
the spite of a sequel going to October
7th 2020 to the Uncharted movie has been
in development hell for over 10 years
but it seems that the cast and crew are
finally set I can't believe it's
actually coming out which uncharted
story do you hope the movie will tackle
or do you want it to tell a brand-new
story let me know as suspected there
will be no mainline WWE 2k game this
year 2k sports officially confirmed that
WWE 2k 21 is not happening which given
that 2k 20 was very poorly received in
fact we gave it a 2 out of 10 it's not
really surprising it was the first WWE
game to be developed by visual concepts
after 2k consciously uncoupled from the
regular series developer UQ's
2k said in a statement we hear you and
we know you want more from the franchise
so here's what we're gonna do we are
applying what we've learned to the
next WWE 2k simulation game with a
renewed focus on quality and fun we want
to ensure the development team at visual
concepts can create a great game that
will entertain grizzled WWE 2k veterans
as well as newcomers who want to climb
through the ropes and step into the ring
for the very first time but if you're
jonesing for your wrestling fix this
year 2k are releasing WWE 2k
battlegrounds an arcade-style wrestling
game which they describe as a completely
new WWE gaming experience okay there
were a ton of glitches and WWE 2k 20
which one was your favorite Bethesda
maybe adding pets to fallout 76 as part
of a recent reddit AMA project lead Jeff
gardener replied to the question our
pets coming soon with edible ones I kid
now that we have our companion system in
the game we are looking to add pets as
well at PAX Australia in October 2018 in
just a month before fallout 76 launched
Bethesda's Pete Hines said to a crowd
that the online RPG would not allow you
to get a dog companion at launch however
he said if players really want to have a
dog in fallout 76 the studio would add
it to its list of features it might
consider for the game after launch now
it seems that it's finally happening
what kind of pet do you want to see in
fallout 76 personally I want a death
hole
alright that's been your save state for
Monday April 27th for all the latest
gaming news keep it GameSpot you can
find me on Twitter at Lucy James games
we'll see you next time
[Music]